all right welcome everyone so our
tutorial is about time series it's
called serious time for time series it's
time to take time series seriously how
to practice that a little bit
so my name is marisha i'm from amsterdam
so i came from amsterdam i am a data
science educator at go data driven and
besides that i'm a data scientist
and a pi data organizer as well so if
you're ever around amsterdam and want to
visit a meetup please do so
and this is my colleague james we're
doing the tutorial together james hi so
my name is james i'm also a data science
educator
go data driven i have a background
in education so i used to be a high
school teacher
hopefully i won't be dealing with any
moody teenage behavior from the audience
today
and yeah so like marisha said i'm a data
science educator at go data driven
so go data driven is a data science
consultancy based in amsterdam
so we do a range of consultancy projects
helping to get companies
started with their data science projects
upskilling and we also have
an academy which does trainings on data
science and data engineering topics
yes so we are the data science educators
that means we regularly do trainings as
part of go data-driven academy we do a
variety of topics so it's trans data
science data science with python deep
learning all those kinds of things
and one of the other ones we do is time
series which is also why we're here of
course
um so that is a little bit about us and
why we're here we're also we have a
quite a big group over here so i want to
invite you to
join our poll over here so you see the
qr code or you can visit the link to get
a bit of an audience impression
it's a great start of course um
how do i switch to the
game that's it for the poll
um well you can also visit the link
that's up there paul ev.com mwinkles274
hey there we go
so we have a couple of questions here
that's also for us to get an idea of how
the audience is because we're with quite
a big group the first question is of
course what did you enjoy most about the
conference so far so we have people
meeting people lightning talks really
like the lightning talls myself as well
um and the food well the feed is pretty
good
so you didn't know a question
can you go to the new question
yeah so the second question here is what
is your job title we have of course
quite a few with both the picon part and
a pi data part of quite a diverse
audience i think so i think i see a data
scientist stuff here
software engineer analyst senior
more engineers more a researcher all
right
consultant all right
and the next question is where are you
from so we came over from amsterdam it's
about a six hour train ride to get here
i uh i met a few a lot of people from
the conference who are from germany but
also
quite a bit more spread out from europe
so quite a diverse audience
i wonder who traveled the furthest
next question what is your current
energy level
it's a medium c1 medium there
someone's very energetic most people
very energetic one person in the
audience who really doesn't want to be
here
but most people are still quite
energetic which is of course a good sign
because we are doing a tutorial so we
have to to do some stuff ourselves as
well
another question so how much python
experience do you have so you're just
starting out one to zero to one years of
experience are you quite comfortable in
python
you
remember working with something that
wasn't 2.7
there's like quite some very experienced
people here then
nice
also good for us to know because we are
doing our time series or tutorial about
time series we will be covering a little
bit of machine learning i do expect like
a lot of people here at my data maybe
have
some experience with it which i think i
also see from nepal
build many machine learning models
most comfortable with the topics don't
necessarily build it themselves and some
of you still starting out
and the last question of course is
for us to know
what do you hope to gain from this
tutorial
so do you want to know a little bit more
about data analysis of time series
because you've never worked with them
before are you comfortable analyzing
time series but would like to learn more
about modeling
or
are you already very familiar with the
topic
so the connection interrupted everything
goes really well to start out the
morning
i guess that everyone's very familiar
with the topic and we just like to pick
up a few tips and tricks so that's a
that's a good
point for us to get started all right
then we'll go to what
oh there we are
quite quite a few people are very
familiar with time series already um
just just for my impression so there was
a tutorial about time series on the
first day as well can i see a raise of
hands of who was with the psychic type
see someone in the oh quite a few in the
middle as well
all right so you must be a little bit
familiar with time series uh then
i think that's a good transition to what
we'll cover in this tutorial then
so
um
yeah obviously we're starting off this
tutorial with a bit of an introduction
um
afterwards marissa is going to take you
through how to perform time series
analysis with pandas probably most of
you have used pandas before but you may
have not taken advantage of all of the
great
[Music]
things that you can do with pandas when
you're working with time series data
afterwards
i'm going to do a demonstration about
time
series modeling and being able to model
seasonality in data
um
and then we've also got
some challenges which we can hand out to
you guys you can have a go up probably
we won't have time to cover them in this
session but be nice to to practice in
your own time and before we finish with
some closing remarks
uh we'll also take uh it says 10 minute
break there we'll take a five minute
break about halfway through
and
just before we get started just want to
make it clear what we will be covering
what we won't be covering in this
tutorial so as i said um introduction to
using time series data with pandas and
some seasonality modeling
obviously this is just an hour and a
half
workshop so we're not going to be
covering we're not really going into
deep learning i mean especially some of
you are new to
machine learning so we're not going to
try and trying to do a crash course in
deep learning and then cover time series
um we're also not going to be focusing
on things like profit or maybe some of
the other time series libraries we
really just want to talk about the
fundamentals and and the actual concepts
in this workshop
okay
so uh it is a workshop we do want you to
code along with us
and have a go yourselves so there's two
options for doing this
um you can either
access this material from github
or if you follow the second link it's
going to take you to like a sandbox
environment where you can access the
jupyter notebooks there as well
so we'll just give people a minute or so
to to get set up before we begin
yeah so we will be uh we will be going
through this tutorial with jupiter
notebooks and we will explain so i will
cover the pandas part james will cover
the seasonality modeling part
and we'll talk about a couple of
concepts there and there will also be a
lot of exercises in there for you to try
out things yourself and see if you can
find some answers to the questions or
the exercises there so we do really
recommend that you visit at least one of
these two links to to make sure that you
have access to the jupyter notebooks and
can actually code along with us
all right so
we are a technical company but we are
having some issues with you know screen
mirroring and the presentation kind of
stuff so don't mind me if i keep on
looking over there because that's my
screen as well so i don't know what's
going on
apologies for that i'll just i'll just
scooch over here so i can see the screen
in the meantime
as well
uh so you should be able to see this
notebook this is the very first notebook
that we have it's the
notebook on that's called time series
analysis
and the goal of this notebook i'm going
to take you through this one and the
goal of this notebook is to get you
familiar with the pandas functionality
that there is to analyze time series uh
so what we'll cover is some time
utilities and pandas uh how you can view
in your time series data and parse those
days properly
and especially some time-based
manipulations and smoothing and these
are basically kind of prerequisites to
the seasonality modeling that we'll be
doing later on
so of course as always the very first
step is what's your shortcut for running
a youtube notebook cell
shift and enter shift and enter okay
it's control enter for me i always
control it
all right so first thing of course
reading in pandas
and we are going to be using uh pandas
with timestamps so
all of your you probably python users so
you're probably familiar with datetime
timestamp is kind of the pandas
equivalent of using datetime so
uh using pi using timestamp we can parse
dates
as you can see over here by uh just
creating upon the timestamp object we
can see what the date is and what the
time is
could you zoom in a little bit
does this work
a little bit more
all right
um so the advantage of using panda's
timestamp is that they support a wide
variety of operations as well so
sure we have the date it knows how to
parse the date but it can also tell us a
lot of other things for instance it can
tell us the amount of days that were in
the month so right here we have it's
difficult for me to read but it's the
february so we can see that there are 28
days in february in total we can also
find out the
week of the year that it is
and what quarter this date belongs to
again all kind of neat functionality
from pandas would be very difficult to
extract yourself so that's where
timestamp comes in
and
another couple of operations that you
can do is you know check what the
difference between two dates is
or what the name of the month is and
these kind of things come in really
handy when you want to create your own
features based on the date that you have
for your data
so in this case we can see that this
date happened to be a sunday
so the very first very quick exercise
we're going to spend too much time on
this but investigate the timestamp
features and methods to see if you can
figure out what day of the year it is
today so we can see here already that
the current date simply pd.timestamp
today and that should give us dave
the date of today
we can check whether we're in a leap
year and we can check something like how
long is it until a public holiday for
instance christmas
so let's take about 30 seconds to one
minute for this
to get you a little bit familiar with
using these timestamps because these are
well this is what we're going to be
using throughout the rest of our
data as well
all right we like i said we're not going
to spend too much time on this exercise
specifically hopefully it gets you this
impression of things that you can get
from timestamp information of course the
reason why we're covering this is
because this is a tutorial but time
series meaning we want to deal with data
that have timestamps
so an important next step is reading in
the time series data and the data that
we're going to be reading in is the data
that we're going to use throughout this
notebook and the other one which is
about air quality in californian
countries between 2007 and 2017.
so in this data set each data point
indicates the average air quality at
that point
and of course if you've used pandas
before you know that when you have a csv
file it is located in the data folder
you can read in the file like this
but as we can see when we read in this
data
we have two columns we have the index of
course we have two columns one of them
is the information that we're interested
in the air quality index aqi
and the other one is the date local
and yes these actually do look like
dates but if we check the information
about this data frame
we can see that this column by default
is not parsed as timestamps so this is
just non it's just strings basically
and we want to make sure that when we
read in the data these are actually
parsed as timestamps so we can do some
nice indexing on it and some other
operations
so when we read in a time series dataset
we adjust it a little bit
so we did make two
so two things we do slightly differently
first of all we set parse dates to true
so in this case that's what you can see
over here parse date is true that will
automatically detect whether something
is a date or not there's also of course
options to
do it with a specific formatting that
you're interested in
and the second thing that we do is that
we set the index not to the 0 1 2 etc
but we actually set it to the date
column
so if we read in this data again now
you can see that it looks slightly
different we only have one column which
is the air quality index and the index
is no longer just 0 1 2 3 4 etc
it is this date that we have over here
and it might seem like a very minor
change but i'll show you why this is
important and why this makes your life a
lot easier when you're dealing with time
data
and you can see here that we now only
have one single column the air quality
index
so why is this nice to do why do we set
the date as the index well
if you know the lock method this allows
you to filter on your data frame and in
this case because we set the date as the
index we can use the log method
to get a range of dates in this case
we're looking for all the dates between
the 1st of february 2008 and the 10th of
february in 2008. we use it as kind of a
indexing method and
as you can see all the dates that we
have now are actually do fall between
that range that we had up there
and another really nice thing about it
is that when you create a plot in pandas
by default it will take the index as the
x-axis and all the columns that you have
as a line for the line to draw well in
our case our index is the dates and our
column is well the information that we
want to plot so that means that when we
do create a plot
we very neatly get all the dates here on
the x-axis and we can see a little bit
of um so there's already some trends in
here so we see what's happening with the
air quality over time
but of course this is just about reading
in the data the nice thing is that
pandas provides a lot of functionality
as well to get more insights from your
data as well
so for instance right now the kind of
information that we have is that we have
it per day right so maybe you're not
interested in the air quality index per
day necessarily but you're interested in
let's say something like the average per
year
well that's where resample comes in
that's a very easy aggregation that we
can do
essentially what we do here is we take
our data frame we set resample it by
well in this case by year but it could
be anything
and then once we resample it we need to
perform some kind of aggregation so in
this case
the mean what does that mean we
basically take
every individual year and then take the
mean over that year and if we execute
this cell
we can see that we have some kind of
information per year about the air
quality index you see that the date that
we have here is the very last day of
that year so the 31st of december
but it is actually about 2007 this is
the information about 2008 and so on and
so forth
the nice thing about resample is that
what we did right now is just re-sample
by year but you can take a lot of
different kinds of periods so for
instance we can also do it per four
weeks for example
gives us some more information you could
do it by month by business month by
quarter uh
lots of different options and if you
want to check out all those different
options you can check out this link over
here for the complete list
of uh of options there
so what we did right now is we took the
mean over that period of time uh but
maybe we're interested not only in the
mean but some other you know some other
forms of aggregations as well
so that's where the ag method comes in
where we state that we want to
use our data frame our air quality index
data frame we want to resample in this
case by month so look at every
individual month and we're not just
interested in the mean we're actually
interested in a couple of different
things in this case that is the mean
but it's also the variance
and these are things that were built in
so we create a column called mean and
the
content of that column should well be
the mean it's just a string that we
passed there same for variance but we
can also create some custom aggregations
for instance what we do here is we
create a column called that we call
spread
that's the first part here and the
second part is
how we actually calculate that spread
meaning in this case we take the maximum
value and the minimum value subtract
those and see what the spread is over
that month
and doing this gives us a data frame
back that on the index has the date
itself
then we're interested in the aqi column
that's why it's all the way over here
there is only one column in our data
frame so we only have the aqi column but
if you would have multiple columns you
would have the mean variance in the
spread for all of those different
columns
so that's what we have here and then we
have that mean column that variance and
that spread
and the names of these columns are
determined by well the first element of
this tuple and the the actual content of
the column is based on the second
element of the tuple so in this case
there were built-in methods
and here we defined one ourselves using
a lambda function
and the advantage here is that we have
our time series data set and using all
this pandas functionality we can create
we can amend it with some other
information so let's say in this case we
only have the index
which are the dates and we have the air
quality index which is the the
information of course but let's say that
we wanted some time-based features there
we want to know whether this time stamp
was in what quarter it was and what day
it was etc
and it's pretty easy with pandas to
create that information so in this case
we take that error uh
quality data frame and we use the assign
method so this may not be the method
that you usually use for creating new
columns it's the way that we prefer to
do it but essentially what we're doing
here is we use the assign method to
create a new column we create two new
columns one is called quarter and one is
called weekday
and how do we create them well we take
the data frame and then we use the index
that is what holds our dates and we use
some of that information from those time
stamps so every time stamp has
information about what quarter that
timestamp was and what the name of the
day was there
and using that information we can create
a kind of an augmented data frame which
doesn't only hold the information about
the air quality index but it also holds
information about the quarter so we see
here that this date was the third
quarter and it was a wednesday and here
we had third quarter and this happens to
be a sunday
so these are some um some nice
functionalities i think pandas has to
offer uh we have a couple of exercises
here as well so
um just to get a bit of a practical
experience with doing this i mean some
of you may have done this before for
some of you it might be new
but what i want you to do is look at
these exercises so there are two here
one of them is compute the average aqi
air quality index per week and find the
week that has the highest or therefore
the worst because the higher it is
the worse it is
and the other way the other exercise
here is to find the weekday with the
worst air quality so which day of the
week had the worst air quality
and as a little bonus it's nice to make
a plot about that
so let's spend a little bit of time on
that if you really don't know
what to do or you're not sure
what the answer is here we also provide
the option to load the answer
i i would say don't do it until you've
tried it but of course you can remove
the comment here load the answer and
then it will show you what we did there
of course multiple ways to do this
and if you are really a little bit
quicker than most of the people in the
room there is a bonus section here on
shifting that we will not be covering
but i think it's pretty interesting
to maybe have a look at if you uh if you
have some time left
all right good luck
all right so i see some people are still
working on it some people are i've
already finished with the exercise so
i'll talk you through the first one
already
because i think there's a there's a nice
little thing in here that you may have
not seen before
so the
question or the exercise here was to
compute the average air quality index
per week
and find the week that had the worst or
therefore the highest aqi
and the interesting here is the thing
here is what you've probably tried to do
is use resample and you saw that we
could do that by year by month etc and
we can also do it by week the thing
however is that if you just use the w
it will assume that there must be one
day that's the first day of the week
right so by default that would be sunday
and i don't know about you but like i
think the week starts at monday not
necessarily sunday so by adding this
little dash month uh what will happen is
it will resample not by assuming that
sunday is the first day of the week but
assuming monday is the first day of the
week you could also of course change
this to wednesday if you would like but
that would be madness
um
so what we do here in order to answer
these questions or what i would do is i
take the data frame that i have
i resample it for by week so in this
case monday specifically but that might
also be sunday for you
and what this will do is it will
separate the data frame into the parts
of the weeks that belong together so you
have so you have a separate data frame
for for each
combination of seven days that starts at
a sunday
and that means that you have seven
values for each of that each of that
part and we need to aggregate these some
way
and what we do here is you could take
the sum but in this case we're taking
the mean
over all of the different weeks in our
data set
but we don't we're not just interested
in the mean we're actually looking
specifically for the worst uh error
quality and that means that the easiest
way to find that for me would be to sort
sort the value so we take the mean we
sort the values and we'll let's see what
the what weeks were the gave us the
highest values well that was this week
in 2007 that ended on
the 24th which is uh
and this was the mean air quality index
over that week
so these were the worst weeks and these
were actually the i would say best weeks
in terms of air quality it's nice to see
that it's a little bit more recent is a
better air quality longer longer time
ago is worse air quality
and the other exercise here was to find
the weekday so which specific day of the
week has the worst air quality
and a nice way to do this
it's not the only way to do this but a
nice way to do this is also to create a
little plot there
so let's see what we
how we approach that
so a little bit more elaborate so we
take the data frame we have the data
frame that for the air quality and in
order to find the weekday with the worst
air quality we are going to create maybe
you did it in a different way and you
got to the same answer but the way that
we did it was we created two different
new columns and these are very similar
they can basically contain the same
information but one of them has it by
name and the other one has it by number
so we have a weekday in terms of
the name of the day sunday monday
tuesday etc and we have the associated
number so sunday being zero monday one
tuesday two etc
and why do we do that well we want to
use that weekday information so what day
of the week it is what string is
associated with it to do a group by
statement that means that we can gather
all the sundays together all the mondays
together all the
the tuesdays together and get the mean
over all of the sundays in our data set
all of the mondays in our data set and
all of the tuesdays in our data sets
why do we also create that weak denim
well it wasn't necessarily really
necessary but you can see that if you
just
let me comment this out really quickly
and this one as well
if we just do it like this
um we do have all the information that
we're looking for it's just that
the days are ordered in a way that's not
really natural i would say like it's
it's alphabetical order i think and i
prefer my tuesday to be after the monday
and then the wednesday afterwards so
that's why we created this other column
here the weekday number because the
monday is zero and then the tuesday is
one and the wednesday is a two so we can
sort by that weekday number
sort the values
and now we have them neatly arranged and
we have the average air quality index
for every day of the week
and of course we're looking for the
worst one
so we're going to plot this to make it a
little bit more insightful it's only
seven values so i could probably find
the worst value as well but it's always
nice to make a little plot
and we can see what the worst day of the
week is here that would be this one over
here friday
so for those of you who got around to it
there's a little bonus section on
shifting if you didn't get around to it
you can always well talk to us after
after the tutorial as well or have a
look at it yourself the material will
stay online for quite some time you can
have a look at it it's quite interesting
but what i really want to tell you more
about is smoothing and it's also because
the smoothing is kind of a prerequisite
for the seasonality modeling that we'll
be doing later on
and the idea here is that we have our
data and we want to get some insights in
what's actually happening so there's a
lot of noise in the data set there of
course
in this case we're going to focus
specifically on one single year
otherwise the the plots will become a
little bit too big but you can do this
for the
other plots as well so we're going to
focus on 2016.
and we can see here that well it's a lot
of spikes a lot of noise but
there do seem to be some trends here
right so it seems like over the summer
holiday period and also in the summer
in general it seems like the air quality
is a little bit better it's lower lower
is better and in this in the winter
the end of the year and at the start of
the year the air quality is a little bit
worse right so this is something that
you can see from this plot
but what we'll try to do is make sure
that that's a little bit more easily
visible
and the way that we do that is with
smoothing because right now we see a lot
of different spikes and i kind of i kind
of had to eyeball what the trends here
are
and we want to get a smooth line through
this to make sure that we can really
visualize that very neatly
and the way that we do that is with
rolling average smoothing so this helps
us discover patterns in the data that
are maybe not as easily noticeable when
it's just all the noise that we see
there
so we create a smoother pattern over
time a smoother line based on the data
points and with rolling average
smoothing we basically take a window and
average in that window so
in pandas we can do this with the
rolling method
so we see that over here the rolling
mean method
and we can set the size of the window
that means the amount of in this case
days that we want to average over
so we can see that here we take that
data frame specifically the 2016 part
and we create a new column here to
visualize and we create that column by
doing the lambda function and getting
our data frame and doing a rolling
average or smoothing over a 20-day
period if i see correctly
and we create a plot with that
so you can see that this is a line that
goes through the data and it kind of
shows what's happening here
and how smooth that line is is really
dependent on the window that you choose
here so if i change this to
7 for instance
you can see that it's a lot more spike
in a lot more closely resembles the
original data well if i make it a lot
bigger
let's let's change it to 50 for instance
it's a very smooth line there's no
right number to choose it really depends
on your data set what gives you the
nicest insight
let's change it back to 20 for a second
and this kind of this is this goes
through our data and it it shows you
what your data is approximately doing
while removing the noise around it
but what you can see and especially when
we use the 20-day period meaning we take
20 days in total we average over that
that's going to be our data point so we
remove all of those spikes but we can
see here for instance yes our line does
follow the data but it lags behind a
little bit so we see
so here there's a bit of a spike in the
orange line and that spike is after the
actual spikes in the original data
so why is that happening well we take a
20-day period but it lags behind so only
20 days later we will actually see the
spike because of that higher time point
over here
and that's maybe not what we're looking
for because it doesn't really it's not
really nice not really nice fit to the
data so one of the ways that we can
offset that is by using centering and by
centering essentially what we're doing
is we manually shift the data points
backwards so they do fall in line with
the data
and there's two ways to do that well one
of them is using the shifting method
that we saw before for those of you who
did spend some time on that but actually
rolling mean when we calculate the
rowing mean it also has the option to
center so what we do here is we take our
data frame we create a column that we
just saw so that orange line over there
which does left behind it's uh it's a
20-day period but we also create a
second column and a second line there
which uh sets center to true
um and a third one which is going to be
exactly the same just to illustrate that
it's it's done in the same way where we
manually shift back the values
and as we can see when we plot this
they are still they're just they're
taking the same number of days so they
are the same lines it's just where they
occur in the graph is a little bit
different so the blue lines are the
original data points the orange line is
really mean that we collect that we
gather without centering and then both
the green and the red line well you
don't see the green line because it's
exactly the same as the red line
we shift back the the data a little bit
to make sure that when we have a little
peak in our data here our smoothed line
also has the peak in the same place and
not you know 20 data points later
because that's that's not really what
we're looking for
um
so rolling average smoothing is
basically a very simple way to isolate
the signal from the noise in the time
series data
there are some drawbacks to this so
first of all you have to choose a window
size we set it to 20 days right now you
could have set it to 50 days or 100 days
or well one day i guess but that would
just be the same as having the original
data
so it's highly dependent on the window
size and you can have a if you if your
windows size is too small you have a lot
of noise still have a lot of noise if
it's too big
you can remove the actual signal that
you're looking for and not really get
some insights
and it always lags behind the window
size unless we center it which is
something that we can do but you don't
always have that information up front
so there's another exercise here so
previously we had the
weekday with the worst air quality so we
said in the previous exercise we saw
that the week
that started on the 24th of december had
the worst average air quality
but we did that by week right so we said
okay which time period starting on a
monday and then ending on a sunday had
the worst air quality
but that might actually not be what
we're looking for maybe we're not
looking for a specific week
defining a week to start on a monday and
on a sunday maybe we're just looking for
a seven day period that was the worst
and maybe that seven day period you know
starts on a wednesday instead of a
monday or starts on a friday
um so that's the the exercise here find
the seven day period that has the worst
average air quality and as you can see
also from the name of the the python
file that holds the answer there is some
rolling average moving uh coming up here
another section that we won't be
covering here today because we're going
to move on to seasonality is exponential
smoothing but it is quite interesting to
have a look at if you're really quick
with the exercise
yeah so so just to repeat your question
so you're looking back 20 days so it's
easy to calculate the value for the 20th
days because you take the previous 20
days but what do you do on day 19 or 18
or 17 when there's no 20 values to look
back at
well if i remember correctly but correct
me if i'm wrong it just takes so let's
say you're on day 15 you want to look
back 20 days you want to calculate the
average it will take those 15 days so
for the very first data point you do
have some data but that is the actual
value that you had on day one
day two would be the average of day one
and two day three would be the average
of day one two and three if that answers
your question
oh so you're you're you're talking about
like you have this peak over here i
think and then the the orange one is
like behind but then the red one is a
little bit soon in a way
yeah so i think this red peak over here
has nothing to do with the peak over
here this red peak has to do with the
peak that we see here and we don't see a
peak afterwards because if you take a 20
day period sure the values are pretty
high over here but right before that the
values are quite low so they average out
to not a very noticeable peak
so i think the the peak that you see
here is not about this data that's
that's happening afterwards but it's
actually about the data just before it
so this peak over here
yeah yeah exactly
is
yeah yeah so that's what you do when you
center that's what we specifically say
when we do centering when you do 20 day
period i don't think it's well it's not
10 days before and 10 days after it's 10
days before and 9 days after or
something like that
but of course by default when you're
dealing with data you don't want to look
into the future right so it makes sense
that by default it just looks back
because that's the data that you usually
have and you don't have data about
what's happening next it's very
difficult to calculate a smoothing
average over the next 10 days when it's
just today and i don't know what the
value is tomorrow and the day after and
the day after will be so that's why
that that option is there so we we can
center if we want but we're looking into
the future and in this case we've
collected data from 2007 to 2017 so we
do have that data but if i wanted to do
that for today i can only look back i
cannot look in the future
all right let's let's load the answer
here and make sure that we have enough
time left for the seasonality modeling
um so the questionnaire and again there
may be a different way that you did it
but the way that we do it here is the
question is slightly different from what
we've seen before before we were looking
for the week where a week is a strictly
defined
monday until sunday period of time or
sunday until
saturday period of time
in this case our question is slightly
different we just want the seven day
period where the values are the highest
and therefore the air quality is the
worst
so this is where the rolling method
comes in and because we're looking for a
seven day period we state that we state
that to seven days
and we calculate the mean
and well if i'll just comment this out
very briefly
we can see that we get a data frame
where
every day has a value associated with it
in the original data frame every day had
in value that was the value of that
specific day
in this case that value is no longer of
that specific day but it is the rolling
average over the seven previous days
so that's what we see here and we're
interested in the seven days the seven
day period of time that is the worst so
how do we get that seven day period of
time that is the worst we're looking for
the highest values here
and we can do that multiple ways you can
sort for instance sort this and see what
what date it is
or we can check the n
largest which gets us the largest value
based on the air quality index column
over here
and when we do that we see that the
period of time the seven day period of
time that was the worst in terms of air
quality is the seven day period of time
that ends on the 20th of december in
because this value is a value that's not
just associated with this particular day
but also the six days before that so
this was the worst seven day period
and you could actually check if you're
interested to see if this is not a
monday but a different day as well if
you're looking at the index
um so what we covered so far is that
this was the first notebook that i
wanted to take you through this is some
functionality that pandas has to offer
to reading your data sets but not only
reading your data sets also get a bit of
insight in your data set there's some
really nice
functionality that it has to offer with
the timestamp being the the pandas
equivalent of date time
and we saw how to properly read in the
time series data set so i really
strongly advise you to always put the
date as the index there because it
allows you to really neatly make plots
and and in and find a filter on the
on the data that you have
and we saw that you could do time
manipulation so you can do aggregations
for instance with free sample which is a
really neat method
and do something like shifting and
getting information about the days that
you have
and the last part that we saw was
smoothing with rolling averages and if
you also had a look at it also
exponential smoothing or weighted
smoothing or expanding windows if you if
you feel like having a look at that as
well
which
which removes the noise from the signal
so that gives you some some insights
into what your data is doing
and based on the techniques we saw so
far you can already answer quite a lot
of questions about your data so for
instance which year had the worst air
quality which five day period has the
largest decrease in air quality between
the first and the last day or something
like does the air quality improve over
the weekend can be really interesting
questions to have a look at and answer
and
just with the tools that we discussed so
far today you should be able or you have
all the tools to be able to answer these
kinds of questions
but of course there's much more to do
with time series and that's when i'm
going to hand it over to james who will
tell you more about seasonality modeling
thank you
uh yeah let's do her short break yeah
okay we'll
um we'll take a a three minute break uh
just in case anyone's desperate for the
bathroom or need some water and then
we'll continue okay
don't get it
well it's five minute timer now
right
okay so we will get started again
very dramatic
okay so um can you just give me a thumbs
up at the back if you can read the
the notebook okay
yeah cool
um so
mauricio has been discussing with you
how you can
perform time series analysis with pandas
and some of the great functionality and
tools that it has we're now going to
move further on to discuss
modeling time series data
and specifically how we can model
seasonality in time series data which
i'll i'll discuss
uh a bit as we go forward so
um just loading in some of the libraries
we're going to be using here and i'm
going to reload in the data that we were
working with before so we don't need to
introduce that again it's this air
quality index data
where we have the higher the value it is
the the more polluted the worse it is
okay so let's get that plot back we've
got the plot from the full data set now
and
you can clearly see that there's some
regularities or some patterns going on
in this data
okay so
um
yeah obviously we're going up
and down
quite a lot as we go through the
different seasons um
as we go through the year so it's as
marissa was saying previously it seemed
like air quality was worse in the winter
than it was in the summer
um any other things that we can see in
this data maybe we can get from the
audience
you can just shout out
there's a downwards trend yeah exactly
so
uh
we can see
that we're kind of oscillating around
between six and ten to begin with but
then as we go towards 2017
um it looks like we're more between two
and six so um in this data set at least
it suggests that the air quality indexes
is getting uh getting better so nice to
have some nice news about climate for a
change
um
but yeah so we've got we've got these
patterns and generally when we're
talking about time series data they can
be categorized into
these four things here so trends like
we've seen here a downwards trend
seasonality
predictable
repeating cycles so here we've got
yearly seasonality in that it's going
yeah from january to december we see
this repeating pattern you might have
daily seasonality so if you're talking
about like power usage in a day probably
you use more power in the day than you
do at night because then you're sleeping
you can also have cyclical components so
patterns with no set period for
repeating
um and then also some residuals
it's going to be almost impossible to
model so
even though we do have some repeating
patterns and there's some clear trends
in this data you can also see it's quite
noisy and
it's obviously going to be pretty
difficult to to completely model that
noise
okay
so
seasonality is very common in business
data the data that's collected by
businesses however it can actually often
obscure the the signal or what you're
looking for
so often something that can be really
helpful when you're modeling or trying
to understand the data is try and
decompose it into these different parts
so
maybe you want to access a trend so you
want to ignore the seasonality because
that's just repeating year on year on
and you want to see the actual general
trend that's happening
now one naive way of doing this
one like maybe simplistic way of doing
this would be to take
a rolling average like mauritia
demonstrated before so
you can see here
i'm taking a rolling average i'm
centering and i'm using a window of 365
and so corresponding to days in the year
and you can see
when we do this with that large window
we're able to essentially smooth out all
of the the seasonality so we can access
the general trend and ignore the the
seasonal repeating patterns
what would be the issues with this if
we're thinking about modeling our data
or thinking about using it to
predict in the future
and again feel free to just shout out or
raise your hands
what if you don't know how long that
seasonality window is
guessed
yeah exactly so i mean i've assumed that
it's a year because that's generally
what i've been able to pick up from the
data it might not always be so obvious i
mean typically with time series data you
can associate it with a regular window
but that's not always going to be the
case
any other suggestions
so
yeah for the benefit of people uh
watching online you can have uh maybe
multiple seasonalities right so you
could have a yearly seasonality monthly
seasonality that would be maybe hard to
access just like this
summertime winter time changes yeah
indeed
um
and
i guess yeah if we're talking about
modeling this data as well um
then
this is going to be insufficient right
we've got no we've got no equation that
we can then we're able to plug in values
and extend this beyond the window of
data that we have at the moment
um
so
yeah so we've we don't end up with any
actual equation that we can use we're
also using centering uh there was a
question from the audience previously
about why don't we automatically
uh center well yeah i am centering in
this occasion here but obviously i can't
use this then for predicting anyway
because
i'm trying to access data in the future
which we wouldn't have
if we're looking for forecasting and
looking ahead in time
okay so um what we're gonna do then is
instead take a
uh try and model this we're gonna use a
very simple model
um just to begin with just to really
demonstrate how powerful it can be so
we're just going to base
our modelling on a linear regression
model
so
what we're going to do
is
make some kind of equation right where
let's see if this works first time oh it
does wow
okay so we're going to have some kind of
equation
where we're going to be able to
yeah have maybe a number that we learn
we're going to be able to put in some
information from the data
we'll probably
add some um
add another term this is the general
form of a linear
regression model and then from this
we're going to be able to predict
that air quality
index
okay
so
what am i going to
input into this model well i can't put
i'm not going to be able to put a date
as an input to a
linear regression model right because
it's just a the date at least as it is
at the moment because we've got this
isn't a number right
obviously we could maybe try and
separate this out
for the time being what i'm going to do
is just consider each date a different
time point so this is the first
date
in our data so
i'm going to give this a corresponding
number zero this is the
the the next one so i'm giving it the
corresponding number one
okay
um
so i'm going to have
a very
a very simple feature matrix and target
vector
so my input x is going to be this 0 1 2
3 4
and i'm going to be trying to predict
well
i'm going to be trying to learn a model
where the target vector is like so the
air quality index
fitting a
simple linear regression model with
scikit-learn here
so i'm passing in
i'm choosing a linear regression model
passing in the data fitting it
and then i can use this model to get
predictions from the data back again
and this is going to correspond to the
linear trend
so you can see here this is the linear
trend that we're predicting
if we plot both of this information
you can then see
in blue the original
data which has the seasonality and in
orange the linear trends
which yeah is
it's not got any information about
seasonality so it's just giving us a
simple linear trend
notice what we were passing into the
feature matrix was 0 1 2 3 up to
however many pieces of data there are in
the
in the data set so i've not given the
model at the moment at least any
information that it could have
seasonality so of course we're expecting
just a simple straight line here
one thing that you might want to do when
you're modeling time series data is put
in some break points often
you'll have a particular event that will
happen
and that affects the trend and the trend
changes from then on
in the context with
specifically in this context we're
assuming that we're maybe aware of this
this uh particular point in time so that
might been a change in the business it
might have been an external change but
something we're able to know an input
into our data so
for example
uh summer 2014 uh there was uh
that some kind of hurricane etcetera
and we see we see a bit of a change in
the data you can maybe see there's a
the the
gradient or the general trends begins to
change around there
so what i can do
or what i'm going to do here is add in
an indicator variable for summer 2014.
so
scroll down a bit
so the first
variable i've added is this after summer
2014 indicator variable so whenever the
the dates
are
below uh august 2014 we have zeros
whenever it's beyond that we have ones
and i've also got an interaction term as
well
what's that's going to do to my linear
regression model
well it's no longer just going to be y
equals
mx plus c
it's going to be
mx so we're still going to be inputting
our
our our days or or whatever so the 0 1 2
3 4 etc
we're going to have another term
which i'll call this x1 i'll call this
x2 hopefully it's not getting too
uh mathematical so we're going to have
this other term here
which is going to be
um
to do with that that
break point after 2014 before 2014
if it's before 2014
that's going to be timesing by zero and
it's not going to be included if it is
after 2014 it's going to be times by one
and we're just going to add on an extra
term
oops
so let me um
i won't include the interaction for the
moment just so we can talk about that
so now we've just got the after summer
2014.
if i include this when i do the linear
modeling you can see at 2014 in the
summer when we get to that point we can
then suddenly going to add on an extra
term
you'll notice obviously we keep the same
gradient at the moment
because all we're doing is adding on an
extra value when we're after
2014 if we want to be able to change the
gradient then we also need to make
something dependent on the what time
stamp it is so that's what we're doing
with this interaction term
so if i add this back on
and we include this information
then we're going to be able to add a
tour add a term that's proportional to
the
date
of the year it is or the time point it
is
okay and so you can see the gradient
starts to flatten out now after summer
2014.
okay
so
we've seen how we can model the trends
we've seen how we can take seasonal data
and effectively
uh ignore the the
seasonality part of it just capture the
trend and also deal with break points
and shifts in that trend
what we're now going to have a look at
is dealing with seasonality
so
at the moment uh we've just been able to
model our data in a
in the for the trend not include
anything seasonal but that's because
when we were passing this data into our
model we didn't give it any information
about the season there's nothing it can
gleam from this data that indicates that
it's in january or it's in december or
if it's in may
this is exactly what we're going to do
with this next part here
so i'm going to use some feature
engineering which marisa generate
marisha
demonstrated
previously and i'm going to add on to
the data some information about what
month
it's in
so we're then going to include this
information
when we go to train our model
now
obviously i can't pass this data in
at the moment
because
we've got this data as strings
it's categorical information
so we need to choose some way of
encoding it
i could choose to orderly encode this
data
right so
i could say january is one february is 2
december is 12.
but that's going to encode
some an incorrect bias
into our data because that's going to
suggest
that
january and february are close together
maybe january's quite close to march
we're talking about january and february
1 and 2 january and march being one and
three but january and december are very
far away from one another because then
we're going from one
to twelve
but actually that's not what we want to
suggest at all when we're doing
seasonality because after december
we come to january again so we want if
anything december and january to be
close to one another
so just converting this to
numbers is going to be insufficient
instead what we're going to do is one
hot encode the data
so if you're not familiar with that
essentially we're going to give
each of the months its own coefficient
so we'll have a coefficient for january
a coefficient for february
and so they'll all be we're going to be
treating these bumps independently
um and that will mean uh that each month
is as close
uh to the other month as well
yes
um
uh i'm i'm not exactly sure what you
mean by polar so the question it was why
not to use polar coordinates why each of
the months are as close to
one another i think essentially with the
one hot encoding that's what we're going
that's what we're going to do
because
what we'll end up with
if i
uh
this
so with our data
instead of having just a month column
right where we maybe have january
february
december hopefully you can read my
terrible writing
we're going to convert this into that
each month
is going to get its own column
so we'll have january
february
december
and then obviously this will ex
all of the months will have their own
thing right so then for january we've
got
one zero zero zero february zero one
zero
and then one and then this has the
effect that each of these points will be
as close to the other
i think maybe that's
maybe we're kind of referring to the
same thing with the polar coordinates so
okay so different but still i guess
we're going to have the same result
there
uh i think so that was a question
again to do with polar coordinates i'm
not going to answer that uh now
obviously because i yeah i think we
would get a bit sidetracked but maybe we
can discuss that
at the end of the session
okay so we've discussed what uh our
model is or the data we're going to be
sharing to our model
and
what i'm going to do here is some nice
scikit-learn pipelining
using the column transformer to just tie
this all together i'm actually using
drop first one hot encoding
um
so i'm only going to be
making 11 months rather than 12 i'm i'm
dropping the variable of january um
not to to go too deep into
to the theory behind that um but that
can be harmful to to the model if we
don't do that
um
so in encoding these variables passing
it through fitting my linear regression
model
and let's just
remove that so we plot the whole data
okay so you can see
you can see now that we've um because we
were passing in seasonal information
we're
able to capture the seasonality
of the data as well
obviously this
our predictions that we're giving it has
these shifts
as we're going from
one month to another that's to do with
the way we've encoded the data right
that it's you have um
you're either in one month and then
you're suddenly in the next month so we
do have these shifts as we switch
between the months
so it's not smooth but we are able to
capture the seasonality of the data
pretty well here
i'm not getting into any metrics for
actually assessing how well we're
capturing that at the moment um
just for the yeah just for the
time restrictions
but obviously we could
maybe you'd want to calculate some
metrics on this data as well here
but with this we are able to separate
the trend and seasonality components of
the model
what i'm getting here
are the coefficients
of the that linear regression model
so when it's february we're adding minus
0.3 to our predictions
when it's march we're adding 2.9 to our
predictions when it's april we're adding
1.8 to the predictions
and when it's
uh
when it's january we're just adding
adding zero we're adding nothing
but what we can do
is take the average of this
so on average for over all of the
different months we're adding 0.86 to
our predictions
so averaging out these seasonal effects
so not actually
worrying about what month we're in and
just always adding 0.86
we can get back the trend
from this model so even though we
encoded the data with seasonal
information and we got out a model that
gave seasonal predictions if we average
out those seasonal effects that we
learnt
we can get the linear trend back
so now we have
uh predictions which capture the
seasonality seasonal information and the
trend we've been able to isolate the
trend
if we then
take
um
uh if we then subtract
our thing or what from the trend we can
then isolate the seasonality so
um let's just make the plot so you can
show you what i can show you what i mean
so i'm plotting
here
um
the just the seasonality and i've made
the seasonality column
let's just show it without the
plot to begin with
okay so this is the the seasonality
column i'm making
and i was able to
make that column by taking the
linear monthly
and subtracting the trend
so taking our predictions which included
seasonality subtracting that trend that
we were able to isolate
and then we can capture just the
seasonality by itself so you can see
um
we've got zero here
just for a reference so there's no trend
going on at the moment or very minimal
trend going on at the moment
you'll notice
that the seasonality effect seems to be
greater during the winter months
and less so during the summer months
so the impact of being in the winter
months is felt
larger than in the summer months that's
what we were able to learn from the data
as well which is an interesting insight
so
uh
just see where where we are with time um
i'll just
what i'm gonna do is just briefly go
over the the next section
to just give you the highlights of it
and
give you the intuition about it
as we are coming towards the end of the
session
and then we'll have some time to just
wrap up and take a few questions
as well so
this uh at the moment our predictions
are nice we're able to capture our trend
and that seasonal patterns in the data
one issue at the moment though is
that we're
we're switching from one month to the
next so we feel a certain effect just
for january and then as soon as we get
to february that effect completely
changes
whereas actually probably that's not
what happens uh in real life
um it's be much
it'd be much smoother so you maybe feel
some effect in january
as you're getting to the end of the
month of january you're feeling that
effect less you're maybe starting to
feel the effect from february
and then as you continue as you get to
the
center of february maybe that's when you
feel the effect the most but maybe you
still feel some effect from january then
it's not just switching from one month
to the next as soon as you go to the
next month you feel something completely
different
so
how you can encode that into your data
is with
a technique called gradual seasonal
filtering
so you can do this with a few types of
filters
one would be a linear filter
just have some code to to make this
filter here just as a demonstration so
i've chosen
so i've got 365 days here
i've chosen 15 just as example so if you
really felt an effect on the 15th day of
the year maybe you
yeah so
on that 15th day you really have a peak
and then as
you go
go on with the year that effect gets
less and less and less
and likewise when you were
getting towards that day that
that effect was getting larger and
larger and larger
because of the particular settings i
have for this filter you can see it's
actually starting to have an effect
right at the end of the year getting
larger and larger and larger until you
get to its peak
okay
so um
what we would like to do then is have
some
of these filters for each of the
different months so
have a filter for january february march
april may so
for each of these different months you
have a you feel it you feel an effect
and it's not the case that you just feel
an effect singularly from one month that
can be the case that you're feeling the
effect from a few different months
okay so then this would be the data that
i'm choosing to add on or i would use to
model with so i'd have a time point
variable and then rather than having
just a binary indicator
showing what month we have we have
something where we're going to feel an
effect depending on what month we have
so you can see
here we've got the 1st of august so you
can see at that point we're kind of
halfway through the well
about equal distance from the middle of
july and the middle of august so the
effect we feel is rather similar as we
go further on in august we feel less of
an effect from july and more of an
effect from august
alternatively
if you want something a little bit
smoother you might want to use a
gaussian filter
right so it's going to be the same idea
only we're not going to have something
linear we're going to have a gaussian
and there's a small exercise here where
you can do some modeling including these
gaussian filters i'll just i won't go
through the code i'll leave that
exercise to you but just to demonstrate
what you can produce with that is
something
a lot smoother
when you're talking about capturing
capturing that data
okay so um
just to summarize those uh
those gradual seasonal filters
uh they are a simple feature engineering
trick
it still allows your variables to be
interpretable and your seasonal effects
to be quantified
obviously with all of these things here
you are encoding some bias you're
assuming some seasonal effects
um
i would say for time series data
that
you do you do as a model and have some
information though already because you
know that effects will happen
and not happen depending on what time of
the year it is
and actually i personally really like
having that opportunity to to be
creative and try and model
those effects which i know are are
happening
we've seen um how we can do that with
just dummy indicator variables that gave
us the the shifting effect depending on
what month we were in we can do it a bit
smoother with the gradual seasonal
filters but you could also try uh maybe
adding a a sine curve
that could also help capture some
seasonal effects
and then once you have this
as well as using it for forecasting you
can use it for outlier detection
and obviously something we haven't
discussed just
through time restrictions is model
evaluation
but that might also be something you
want to look at and so you can properly
compare the models you're creating
okay so
just have a
have a few closing remarks and then i
think we'll have time still for a few
questions yeah
okay
so um
just to briefly summarize what we
covered
mauricio took you through timestamps
time-based aggregations creating
time-based features
and smoothing time series data we then
discussed time series decomposition
modelling time series data
and engineering seasonal features
so obviously this was just an hour and a
half
uh workshop so we tried to fit in as
much as possible
um but
obviously there's a lot more to cover
you'll find in
[Music]
here we also have a third notebook which
create has some extra exercises that you
may wish to cover
um
but yeah if you're
really interested in uh
in time series and you'd love to learn
more with us we do have a two-day course
which allows us to take a bit of a
deeper dive
uh into this so there's a short link
there on the time series training
yeah we're based in amsterdam of course
so we do have in-person trainings but we
also do a lot of trainings online so
this is something that you could join
remotely as well if you're interested
and uh
yeah we do have a booth here so
some of you might have seen us already
we had the the dropbox challenge the
r2d2 has been handed out now
but it would still be great for if you
uh come up and have a chat with us later
on
[Applause]
okay
yeah i think we have some time for some
for one question
so make it a good one
pressure's on
yeah alternatively we'll be around if
you want to come up afterwards up to you
no questions whatsoever
right
okay
all right
thank you
[Applause]